okay welcome everyone to our class today
and first we're going to start out by
going over one of my games it's a quick
game that I want at 20 20 moves 21 moves
and after that we're going to proceed
and study some end games and I also have
some Indian positions and a couple of
tactical positions I'd like to show you
okay so I'm playing with the white
pieces I play d4 d5 c4 c6 okay so when
opponent plays c6 here so first you need
to know the name of this opening how
many people know the name of this
opening so we have - what's the name
Slav defense okay
so this is the Slav defense opening and
there are many different types of
openings they can play against you but
this one in particular is the Slav
defense okay now he plays c6 I decided
to play Knight c3 developing one of my
pieces Knight f6 and III the reason I
played e3 because you know I thought in
some cases if it takes I would like to
be able to capture back with a bishop
okay it's a normal solid move to play
but there is a problem there is a small
problem when you play e3 who can point
out the problem okay you know so we know
what is it doing it's actually opening
up the diagonal for the bishop but what
is the problem that is causing
very good thinking yes blocking the dark
square bishop okay so now we cannot do
anything perfect
so you go here that's why you know
that's the drawback about this novel is
a 6 ok now what should I try to do here
what do you think
all this development is very important
right so there to see if we can try to
continue developing more pieces right
yes neither three of course a lot of
times in the opening you need to make
logical looks that I look natural okay
so here if the night development looks
natural
my opponent plays b5 and that was the
point of the last of a six so he can try
to play b5 to try to gain a little bit
of space on the queenside
okay and here I have couple of options
here I can capture here I can play b3 or
I can play the move in the game so
what's the move that I played here a bit
different than the b3 and C takes d5
because if you can try to gain space and
kind of advance to the opponent's
position that will give you some
advantage so what's the idea here what
can we do here so we can gain the space
yes
yeah but then then actually I think this
might not be the best book because he
takes back okay well
yes but you lost okay okay let's first
raise your hand yeah first the first
thing we raise your hand if you want to
suggest something but let's try to
understand what just happened okay
what's the value of the night everybody
know here right
three pounds so when you take the pawn
here I take you take you get how many
pounds only two right but you lose a
whole piece so you know technically
you're done material here so it's not
very good for you okay to go for this
yeah I mean you don't really have an
attack sometimes if you have an attack
you can go for this but you need to have
a really good follow up to do this
otherwise it's just not going to lead to
much okay so the move what's the move
that I played oh I do want to take I
wanted to gain space you don't gain
space by taking yeah you gain space by
yes you gain space by advancing okay
remember that you advance that's how you
gain space you get into the opponent's
position because look at this the first
one through four this is for white five
six seven eight that's for black so my
pawn is now in his camp okay so it's
very important you may think okay what's
the you know a big deal about the pound
there you know but that point is going
to actually create problems for him he's
going to take away squares so my pawn is
in his territory okay so it's good for
you to have that they have that
opportunity to have a pawn on that rank
okay you have a question pawn structure
is good everything is great about the
position is one thing that is just not
as good that I would have liked what's
the only small problem in this position
for white yes
yeah I wouldn't worry about that too
much but not concrete it's just like
there's just one piece that is just not
very good here that I would have in
ideally I would have liked it to be
maybe somewhere else so which piece is
that excellent the Oxford bishop is
blocked if I can magically play Bishop
f4 here it would have been fantastic but
unfortunately I already pushed upon but
in chess you can't have everything
remember that don't try to have this
this in interest it's a compromise you
can't have everything sometimes you know
you have to just go for it that if you
think it's more important okay so it
goes here now before the point of before
is strengthening my pawn on c5 and
getting ready to play this move a5 and
attack my opponent okay because he's
going to try to aim for this if I break
so I want everything to be protected
okay put in ready for this if I break
and also now I want to play a four and
put pressure this is the idea to play a
four put pressure on b5 now he plays a
five is a good player so it plays a five
now trying to put pressure on before
now he's trying to put pressure because
otherwise I would have played it now
what should I do here how should I try
to react to this he is threatening now
to take on before I can't play three
yeah because he just takes and then the
rook is hanging I can't take so what can
I do
think about it
okay everybody focusing everybody
focused on the screen okay okay yes
Bishop and that meets kinda good
yeah you could do that but yeah but the
pawn bishop doesn't look in it's like
blocked behind this path I want to get
something else here
yes now if I take he just goes Queen a5
you're helping him develop I actually
thought I should just play Queen b3
because this way I protect before and
I'm getting ready to play the move a4
okay you could lock it but if you locks
it I just retreat and I violated this
position is better for me because the
way it works here now I can do this
sacrifice idea let's say in some point I
could do this idea because I will be
gaining three pounds okay one two and
three if I gained three pounds then I
can go for it okay because it's three
connected passed pawns so it's very very
important okay to remember that that's
why I wasn't too worried about it and he
didn't do that he played a five very
aggressive but perhaps you should have
been a little bit more cautious you know
doing this he thought he can try to play
actively and put pressure so I took
Knight takes e5 he takes back I took
and now he goes Knight g4 and this is
the reason now why I wanted to show you
this game because of this one particular
move here it's a very very pretty move
here because my opponent played bit
strange you know like he tried to play
aggressively while he's not developed
and there are consequences okay there
are problems here that I can take
advantage of here so let's think about
it for a few minutes and find the
tactical idea that will basically give
me the winning position here what is
that tactical idea here
okay see
what is that idea
yes
yeah but okay he just takes the pawn on
e5 you could do that but okay it's not
big big difference yeah it just takes
yeah now and he will take something else
can we carry because this B 5 squared is
kind of weak here so this B 5 B Phi upon
it even though it's protected but there
might be some some ideas here you can do
you know don't be afraid to sacrifice
when you see the opponent pieces are not
well-developed look for those sacrifice
ideas okay so what can we do here
okay keep working keep Kuan check where
is it going to go
and then what do you do absolutely push
the pawn if it moves away keep pushing
it exactly do you see that now I win the
Queen that's what I'm trying to do okay
okay so that's why I decided to take on
b5 you know because if it takes I Bishop
b5 because my opponent is not well
developed that's why I'm trying to play
actively like this and now if he doesn't
do much I will go 96 he captures I can
take back with a pawn so he takes back
on e5 now
my knight is under attack but I don't
want to just move it we will try to
develop okay can you try to get more
development
you see developing movie that will
attack something yes absolutely we
should be too if you look at the
position how many pieces he has
developed how many pieces he has
developed
yeah pawns you don't count constant cut
only pieces and how many pieces you have
developed White has developed
three three pieces develop and now the
night is under attack so he's not sure
what to do now
the night is under attack he's already
down upon so he plays Knight see her
trying to play active now you could
actually you could think that oh I can
just take yeah maybe but the problem is
he takes back you take you take here
thinking oh great
check and I win the rock but only when
you arrive here you will realize you box
it and protects it you blocks it and
protects the look that's right here okay
now he is isn't it pretty pretty good
here so that's why 95 takes we should be
two now on a group night is under attack
ninety-four we don't want to take this
piece now he is threatening to take our
night okay this is already a serious
threat so we have to do something about
that threat
we gotta move the night but where which
square will be the best there for the
night
yes aha go ahead you could go to d6 but
he's got couple of squares guarding a
couple of pieces guarding that like you
know this he could maybe take you back
this way yeah and then take not so clear
let's try to move somewhere that night
so we can attack something can you move
the knight and attack something this is
a weak pawn here you move the knight and
attack
where where can we move here tonight to
attack yes very good
of course 94 and now you attack the pond
you see it and now he needs to do
something
he plays Queen c7 trying to protect and
now continue continue developing the
pieces quickly okay so you gain more
lead in development yes so which piece
can you develop here that is not
developed yet
okay
okay which one is your choice of course
of course you his knight is active he's
Knight is in your territory okay
that move you don't even think about it
you developed it and can take developing
and taking you know that's excellent it
means you didn't waste any time to move
the piece and then capture something so
if you can develop and take that's not
excellent you're gaining time you have a
question
yeah well he's not winning it I just
took his knife so he starts just
capturing back so he's just going to
capture back of course what else you can
do otherwise he's down a piece now
what's the move here of course there is
no reason not to take it let's increase
our advantage to 2 pounds now now he
plays Bishop a six but he's got some
ideas behind it's a strong claria is not
just giving up fancier left and right
please thinking about Bishop e6 now the
Queen is under attack he wants to take
my queen what should I do here I have
some options but the question is what
what is the best he wants to take now
yeah he wants to take our queen and grab
to do something here we've got to do
something about that right what do we do
aha 9 2 P 5 that's blocking it but this
would have been excellent if you didn't
have a pawn here but the problem here is
how many he's got on this one too so
when he takes you can't take back
because it's got protecting ok but you
got it that's a good idea if the pawn
wasn't there
that would have been actually the
strongest move that would win the game
for you but unfortunately we can't do it
right now
ok but now what do you think
yes
howdy five is a possibility but then he
takes then Bishopsgate open do you want
it to be open when here's bishops or you
want it closed think about it
I mentioned bishops are strong where
when it's open here so don't make it
open keep it closed that's what you want
to keep the position cause when opponent
has bishops yes absolute the Queen c2
simply retreating at this point I have
two extra pounds don't forget I have two
extra pounds I have the advantage here
so I just need to be accurate he goes
here he sees the problem I'm problem you
know I want to go check so if you had
gone here I would have simply say check
you would have gone here and I would go
Knight f5 putting pressure here here big
trouble for him okay now this is week
two
so he played Bishop e7 developing his
vision and this bishop is stopping me
from counseling unfortunately I cannot
castle but it's ok I can go for the
attack but in order to do that I have to
play energetically so what is the move
here who is going to find a strongest
move here the game ended in just few
more moves just few more moves and the
game is over
yes
9f5
you could go on i-25 but I think it's
stronger to start out with Queenie for
because when you play Queenie for that's
called centralization rather when you
put the Queen that's centralizing it and
now I'm threatening this but
additionally I'm threatening also to
take this so I got a lot more threads
going okay additionally you got it so we
got that so now he goes castle because
what else he can do he's getting you
know Kay is in the middle of the board
he's in big trouble so he's got a castle
and the move that will basically finish
him off fish strong move that finishes
in a fish this is my game from 2010 US
Open tournament in California yes
that's good but when you see good move
what do you do
what did world champion Emanuel Alaska
say when you see a good move anybody
know this code very famous called
find a better one yes look for a better
one okay when you see a good move look
for a better one so 96 is a good move
can you find a better wonder not always
capturing is the best yeah sometimes
maybe placing the piece to a more active
square will be better what is the better
one
of course 95 rookie eight only move
because I have two pieces attacking on
the bishop one two and now look at this
this is hanging to end if he goes here
now I take n do you see the mate in two
one two one two
okay just focus here don't move the
chair yeah okay
I don't see raise your hands if you have
it yes in the back
absolutely one to see it so he cannot do
that
so he goes rook f8 and what's the
winning move here
don't Russia you're so close to the
victory but you have to still show
precise play now you don't just think oh
it's over I know I can do anything
because one mistake and he's going to
get back into the game you don't want to
allow him to get back into the game
sickling g4 it's it's possible Queen g4
but g6 let's say
Bishop g7 is a winning move - I believe
Bishop g7 is winning - but I want to
something else that I want to take and
attack something you see another capture
because you take with the bishop because
the knight is guarding it right so can
you do the other way around now can you
the other way okay let's see yes
well if we take only seven he just takes
back then we don't have the attack
anymore excellent because because now
I'm threatening this piece okay you
played Bishop c5 tactical he's trying to
do a tactic on me and now Knight takes
rook and now my opponent finally
resigned because if he takes back with
the rook I just take it and if he plays
Bishop before check this looks like
scary a little bit because my King is
now going to be under attack looks scary
you know what to do because if you move
the King he starts checking and get into
trouble so what do you do
yeah King is under attack and move the
King but we don't want to do that but we
don't want to move the King because he's
going to check us and don't forget that
his queen is under attack to his queen
is under attack that's important
well not he's checking you you have to
do something about the check do
something about the check what can you
do
only one will get out of the check or or
exactly sacrifice the Queen to eliminate
it yes brilliant takes back what do you
do then capture the Queen right that's
it there you go
and you still fortune ok ok ok great low
but raise your hand yeah if you have
question yeah go ahead
take the bishop yeah we have a whole
rook remember whole extra rook but we
could also try to mate him
that's also possible but but just in
case we can exchange Queens we have a
whole rook
okay okay great